هكذا يرى مكلنش نفسه قيادته للحركه
الاحتجاجيه في قطاع النقل وتشدده لتامين
مطالب اعضاء نقابته دفعه الى واجهه احداث
الاضرابات التي خنقت بريطانيا واربكت حياه
الناس فالى اي حد تعب الناس من موجه
الاضرابات الاخيره التي عطلت مرافق اساسيه
في بلاد
اجمعين
واتفهم لماذا
فكرته وادرك سبب اضرابهم والى اي حد قد
يذهبون وهو موقف شخص الى اي حد قد تكرهه
الاضرابات الواسعه التي تشهدها بريطانيا
منذ اشهر قد تكون الاكبر في تاريخها خصوصا
مع اعلان نقابات عده في قطاعات الرئيسيه
في وجه حكومه نتيجه خلافاتها الحاده معها
بشان رفع الاجور والمعاشات التقاعديه
والامن الوظيفي
وبعد التعنت حكوميه طويل وافقت الحكومه
على الجلوس مع قاده العمال لحل النزاع
النقابي لكن بشرط ان تكون اي زياده في
الاجور مقبوله التكلفه ومعقوله ومع التضمر
شرائح عديده من المواطنين تاثرت بشده
بالاضرابات اطلقت الحكومه مناقشات بشان
تشريعات تحد من تاثيرات الاضراب في قطاعات
حيويه لضمان حد ادنى من الخدمه والسلامه
خلال ايام الاضراب
في ظلي صراع الحكومه مع النقابات اصبح
لزمن على الناس الان التاكد من امكانيه
الحصول على ابسط الخدمات الاساسيه التي
يحتاجونها مع كثره الاضرابات واختلاف
مواعيدها ومددها واقع جديد في البلاد
يفاقم الهموم المتزايده لاسيما لناحيه
التامين مستلزمات الحياه اليوميه في ظل
ازمه غلاء معيشه غير مسبوقه مصطفى زاروه
العربيه